so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about the conflict that
emerged leading to Deadpool and
Wolverine fighting for the first time
and the reason for this is because if
I'm going to be honest with you all the
Weisse actually pretty awesome
so the conflict between Wolverine and
Deadpool actually has its roots in a
couple of different characters the first
being a woman named silver sable while
she isn't necessarily an integral part
of this story she is important for why
Deadpool and Wolverine fight in the
first place with Deadpool established in
our previous videos as having been hired
by the son of cable to kill cable
following this failed attempt Deadpool
maintained his role as a mercenary while
various stories after his first
appearance in New Mutants issue number
98 had Marvel throwing him into popular
publications like Avengers and x-men in
an effort to both find a place for him
as well as exposed readers to his
character the escapades that Deadpool
was involved in led him to issue number
23 of silver sable and the wild pack and
trained by her father to become an
expert in almost all forms of
hand-to-hand combat the Silver Sables
involvement and the wild pad was very
similar to the TV show the a-team and
that they were effectively a group that
could be hired to carry out requests
from almost anyone as long as they were
willing to pay as a result the actions
of the silver sable and wild pack drew
the attention of an organization called
the Genesis coalition as a clandestine
group not unlike Hydra and occasionally
coming in a conflict with both Hydra and
the wild pack and while only appearing
about 21 times of Marvel Comics between
silver sable issue 6 through 27 and
issue number 23 the Genesis coalition
had hired Deadpool to kill silver sable
engaging the wild pack in the streets of
New York and taking the fight to the
sewers the group is eventually joined by
daredevil after a battle between
Daredevil and Deadpool Wade's actually
defeated what appears to have been
offered as sum of money by silver sable
to simply walk away from the genesis
coalition's contract now while this
isn't explicitly stated initially once
the story transitions away from Deadpool
and silver Sables back amongst the wild
pack the she reveals a she'd actually
paid Deadpool three times the amount
that Genesis coalition was paying him in
order to drop a contract and to even go
as far as to keep him on retainer which
basically meant that she had hired him
now the other half of this equation is
Wolverine the fight between himself and
Deadpool takes place in Wolverine vol 1
issue number 88 and with these stories
being part of a larger story arc but
each issue being self contained meaning
that they can be read on their own
Wolverine is actually heading to meet a
person named garrison Kane like silver
sable Kane's not really important for
this story but he does need a little bit
of explanation here the reason why is
that as a former member of cables team
called Six Pack which consisted of a
ragtag group of military personnel Kane
had actually defected the reason why
isn't important for this video but what
is important is that at some point he
almost died but was surgically altered
and became a cyborg resulting in
metallic arms and legs giving him some
strength and speed that was beyond what
he had previously had furthermore as we
discussed in one of my original Deadpool
videos and prior to the onset of his
cancer his encounter and subsequent
experimentation at the hands of Weapon X
which turned him into Deadpool Wade
Wilson had been in a relationship with a
woman named Vanessa Carlysle while
Vanessa Carlysle would go on to
undertake the name copycat and fall into
the life of a mercenary as well the word
that she had set herself on and becoming
a mercenary eventually led her to
engaging in a relationship with garrison
Kane and so all of these subplots
eventually come to a head as we pick up
with issue number 88 and the first fight
to ever take place between Deadpool and
Wolverine
this'll be encounter between Deadpool
and Wolverine is a perfect example of
hitting the ground running returning
from a trip to the fictional country of
majeure pour alongside gambit in issue
number 87 Wolverine finds himself
stopping in San Francisco in order to
check up on garrison Kane to ensure that
everything is on the up-and-up
after realizing that Kane's apartment
has been broken into
Wolverine enters only to encounter
Deadpool with this story taking place
prior to Joe Kelly's revamp of the
character as comedic rather than serious
this version of Deadpool is both violent
and cunning immediately opening fire on
Wolverine
Logan reveals that while he is aware of
the Deadpool name that he's never
actually met him before on the other
side of this coin
Deadpool's arrival at garrison Kane's
apartment is due to the fact that he's
looking for Vanessa the reason for this
being that following his hiring by
silver sable and his failure to kill her
his motives as an assassin or perhaps
his ability to be an effective mercenary
had basically been called into question
and so what he was looking to do was to
meet with Vanessa and perhaps find some
way to reestablish himself as being
capable but while the initial
confrontation between Wolverine and
Deadpool is short and that is only a
couple pages long this two-page fight is
perhaps the most brutal the two had
engaged in one neither will really
answer the questions of the other and
spend most of their time simply throwing
out one-liners what I'd like you to do
here is pay special attention to
Deadpool the reason why is because his
jabs and comments to Wolverine are
elements of Joe Kelly kept when he took
over the title and so for those of you
who may have read a Deadpool comic in
your time this is the reason why his
method of speech seems so familiar here
however after stabbing will flank to the
back and puncturing his heart and lungs
Deadpool departs realizing the garrison
quena Vanessa appear to be at a play
rehearsal but following this we learned
that where normally Wolverine would have
been able to heal almost as fast as
Deadpool this story actually takes place
after the events of fatal attractions
when Wolverines adamantium had been
ripped out of his body by magneto but
during this story his healing factor was
pushed to his limits and burned out for
a time but as he progressed forwards
issue number 88 in his solo series his
healing factor had returned but it's
still a little slower than he used to be
now realizing the Deadpool is pursuing
garrison Kane and
happy had at their play Wolverine
manages to hail a cab in order to arrive
and try to save them the transitioning
back to Deadpool we find that he has
arrived and is currently encountering
Kane providing a bit of banter and
touching on his first appearance with
New Mutants issue number 98 when he
fight Kane in order to get to cable a
Deadpool taunts him a bit in stating
that he hopes his fighting skills have
improved now Kane himself doesn't seem
to want to fight in this situation
whether this is because of his previous
encounter with Deadpool or not is
unknown but he simply tells Deadpool
that he needs to leave
at which point Deadpool makes it known
that he's here for Vanessa he continued
with their skirmish Kane states that
whatever existed between Vanessa and
Deadpool is over now there is a little
back story to this involving the origin
of Deadpool which is covered in a
separate video but Kay's intention along
with Vanessa is to basically leave their
mercenary lives behind and start over
which is the reason why they live in San
Francisco at the moment and so as the
battle continues Deadpool uses a
flashbang of sorts to temporarily blind
Kane and give himself the upper hand at
this point
copycat joins the fray but as a rather
inexperienced mercenary whose ability is
kin to mystique but more enhanced and
that she can copy powers in addition to
physical appearances she does what she
can against Deadpool but just doesn't
have the physical prowess necessary to
overcome his fighting technique or his
healing factor with Vanessa down and
turning his attention back to Kane and
Deadpool forces him to basically make a
choice if he truly loves Vanessa and
would do anything for her he can either
stop the sword that will be thrown at
Vanessa or he can stop the sword that
will land in his head lunging towards
Kane and throwing the sword of Vanessa
who sits behind him the group is met
with the arrival of Wolverine smashing
into the building and knocking the sword
out of the way before it can hit Vanessa
who's basically too weak to move
following her skirmish with Deadpool the
entire group turns her attention to Wade
however with Deadpool's healing factor
returned to him combined with garrison
Kane's fighting skills and whatever
Vanessa can do
Deadpool realizes that the deck is
basically stacked against him but the
only grenade as a distraction he simply
bails out bringing the entire conflict
to an end
so following this story marvel's attempt
to give deadpool more exposure to
readers and hopefully beefed up the
popularity of his character turned out
to be a monumental success with
Wolverine being one of the most popular
characters they had at the time seeing
him come face to face with a mercenary
that could best him immediately caught
the attention of fans with his own
series titled the circle chase having
already been established in 1993 this
story set the stage for everything
coming after including appearances in
Avengers vol 1 issue number 366 Secret
Wars part 2 as well as John Kelly's run
in 1997 and a ventricle grudge match
with wool rain and cable and Deadpool
issue number 43 with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it and I
will catch you guys later peace